bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors plusieurs milliers
de personnes ont manifesté hier à berlin
contre les nouvelles restrictions
sanitaires on le disait quel impact a eu
cette manifestation en allemagne je
pense que les gens ont été choqués par
le nombre de participants à cette
manifestation
ce mercredi la police a dit mercredi
qu'il pourrait y avoir jusqu'à quatorze
mille personnes je ne pense pas qu'on a
atteint ce stade mais en tout cas sans
doute plus de 10000 c'est une estimation
très conservative plusieurs personnes
ont été arrêtées lors de cette
manifestation certains pour des chefs
d'inculpation assez grave
ils se sont retrouvés devant le juge
avant que leurs pieds touchent le sol
il ya également eu des blessés dont
certains gravement blessé dans un cas
une policière a été tapée alors qu'elle
était au sol ce sont les groupes qui
manifestaient qui sont des organisations
très particulière il y avait beaucoup
d'organisations rassembler beaucoup de
points de vue très très disparates
il y avait des gens d'extrême droite des
complotistes des personnes qui
considèrent que le corona virus n'existe
pas a été inventée de toutes pièces
il ya également des personnes qui ont
perdu leur emploi ou qui risquent fort
de perdre leur emploi et donc leurs
moyens de survie à cause des
restrictions mises en place pour essayer
d'empêcher la propagation de la copie 19
lorsqu'on étudie ce groupe c'est ce que
l'on voit c'est que environ 30 % plus de
30 % des personnes sondées par
l'université de leipzig en allemagne
disent que pour eux il pourrait y avoir
un complot ils pensent qu'il pourrait y
avoir une éminence crise derrière tous
ces événements si l'on regarde les
slogans de cette foule heures mercredi
si l'on regarde ce qu'il disait sur par
exemple télégramme on disait que les
canons à eau utilisée elle les asperger
de produits chimiques qui a deux vaccins
donc il ya des idées assez assez
farfelue alors vous l'évoquez en fin de
manifestation la situation a dégénéré
les forces de l'ordre ont utilisé des
canons à eau pour disperser les
protestataires
est ce que cela peut exacerber les
tensions entre le gouvernement allemand
et les protestataires anti restrictions
je pense que le gouvernement va prendre
du recul s'agissant des antilles masque
bien sûr ils veulent maintenir le droit
et l'ordre
ce que nous allons voir c'est que lors
de manifestations futures il va y avoir
des contre manifestations
il y à des groupes militants par exemple
proches des partis écologistes et des
partis de gauche allemand qui disent que
lorsque les prochains anti conformiste
les antilles corona se rassemblent alors
il y aura des contre-manifestations et
je pense que cela pourrait mener à des
tensions supplémentaires d'être même
plus de violence de ces manifestants
contre le coronavirus ces violences ne
sont pas donc tourné seulement vers la
police mais également vers les gens qui
sont là pour les empêcher de manifester
alors parmi ses opposants certains
accusent angela merkel d'imposer une
dictature
pourquoi ces restrictions adoptées pour
contrer la deuxième vague de comics
sont-elles mal reçue par une partie des
allemands l'allemagne qui est pourtant
un des pays européens qui a le mieux
géré
la première vague épidémique on étudie
les restrictions les changements à cet
acte de défense contre la propagation
le problème est que des avis des
conseils ont été transformés en loi et
ce qui permet à la police de faire
respecter le port du masque la
distanciation sociale la police
coordonnée aux gens de rester chez eux
des couvre feux peuvent être mises en
place et cela n'est pas une bonne
nouvelle pour les gens et ils n'aiment
pas l'idée que tout cela puisse être
appliquée par la police ce mercredi la
ft le parti d'extrême droite allemand
lutter au parlement contre l'adoption de
cette loi et ils sont fins de vous
contre doute ces mesures contre le
coronavirus il y à des élections bientôt
au bundestag et il pourrait perdre tous
leurs sièges c'est sans doute possible
qu'aujourd'hui ils perdraient tout leur
siège si les élections avaient lieu
donc ils sont vraiment engagés et ils
ont un langage très émotionnelle autour
du coronavirus et les gens s'intéressent
beaucoup à ce dilemme
en allemagne il y a eu cinq mille
nouveaux cas de coronavirus récemment en
allemagne est presque plus de 300
nouvelles morts donc c'est un problème
majeur et certains partis d'opposition
se s'implique dans le sujet merci
beaucoup un peter oliver d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes correspondant de rtl berlin